tour in Vietnam as a 9th Infantry
Division battalion commander in the book
he explains the hit-and-run tactics he
employed from his 1966 handbook Vietnam
primer to transform the troops into a
mobile counter guerrilla force this
program is an hour good evening ladies
and gentlemen welcome to this very
special event featuring our honored
guest colonel david hackworth as you
know his latest book is steal my
soldier's heart he is here to discuss
the book and after the discussion we
will
have a signing he can sign your books
and answer questions I have distributed
cards if you have a question for Colonel
Hackworth please write it on the card we
will collect the cards and he will
answer your questions so here is the
person you really want to meet Colonel
david hackworth thank you and welcome on
this very very cool Elton has a day
my pleasure being here and you are
witnessing America's most reluctant
author full stop did not want to write
this book for many reasons I had taken
Vietnam as many of you have and locked
it up behind a whole bunch of doors in
my head never wanted to go there again
but my wife and wives can be reasonably
persuade see felt that we should tell
the story and her motivation was and
she's the co-writer of the book was and
that's Elise England she won't be a
quick I don't know why and she had gone
to our annual reunion and the battalion
has met every year for the past twelve
years in different spots and what she
saw was not what I saw what I saw was 19
year old boys who were now 55 but to me
there will always be 19 20 year old
voice and she saw an incredible pain she
saw these heroes
not having closure with her Vietnam
experience and she felt it be imperative
that we tell their story not just the
story of the 4th battalion 39th infantry
but the story of all of those who served
in Vietnam that was two and a half
million folks they served on the ground
in the air and at sea and all of those
who served in the Armed Forces
during that time Germany Alaska the
Panama stopping the Soviet Union from
coming our way that makes seventeen and
a half million folks then there were
about fifty million more folks who were
like my wife who did everything they
could to get us out of Vietnam running
around putting flowers and rifles and
waving placards and demonstrating and so
on now all 70 million of us for one
reason or the other carry guilt those
who went carry guilt those who didn't go
feel really terribly that they didn't
get a leg blown off or get shot at or so
I'm jumping and those that protested now
look at their demonstration and they
feel guilty so there's 70 million of us
that haven't recovered from the Vietnam
experience so it was her thought and
once you took the shotgun away from my
head it became my thought that if we
tell their story it might bring closure
on the Vietnam exercise because those
men and women who fought in Vietnam were
noble heroes the war was not a noble war
but they were noble people and somewhere
along the line our citizens got confused
and when they came marching home they
didn't get the reception that their
fathers got when they marched home from
the big war
after slaying the Nazis and the Japanese
no parades no thank-yous no welcome
homes they got your baby killer they got
you are a Nazi you are a murderer
you are frequently veterans from Vietnam
were spit upon and so they eternal eyes
this pain and many of them kind of like
me locked their experience behind a
whole bunch of doors and many many of
the sons of Vietnam veterans have told
me they had never heard their fathers
tell them of experience of Vietnam the
father's never went there so it's my
hope that we will at long last
understand what Vietnam was about and
the great heroism of the Vietnam
veterans and you have to understand the
setting of this battalion was 1968 69 if
you understand the war we got into it in
65 with the first US units all regular
units and then we morphed into a draftee
army by 1969 most of your infantry
battalions were 95% draftee and the
leadership wasn't the like it was on the
earlier tours
now these draftees were 14 15 years old
in 1965 so they watch the blood pour out
of the tube every night 65 66 67 68 they
watch their brothers come home shia legs
cheyenne arm maybe they watched their
brothers not come home or the kid next
door not come home so they well
understood by the time Uncle Sam said we
want you get on the bus
off to the induction Center basic
training that the war was not when
all yet they did exactly as their
fathers did 20 years before they marched
off to the war and and we didn't treat
him too well when they came back so I
had the great privilege of commanding a
battalion of these soldiers and so
that's their story and how I put the
story together with my wife was first of
all I had my memories and then I had a
fair amount of recordings from that war
Journal notes notebooks and all the
things that soldiers and commanders
would all kind of tuck away plus a lot
of letters home then I went to the
National Archives and went through their
records got the battalion log which gave
minute per minute what happened during
the time of this battalion and from that
I was able to contact about 300 soldiers
from the battalion they were soldiers in
the battalion who supported the
battalion the Redlegs for example the
chopper pilot the fighter pilot the kid
that drove up the truck with bringing
the beans and bullets we got all their
stories and put them together and my
wife said well now what you'll do is
just interview all these guys I said
Roger that'll be easy and I say how you
doing Greg attack call colonel sir how
are you forget that stuff that was 33
years ago
please call me act sure hack sir no no
forget the hack sir style just what I
want to know is what happened on 23
March yes sir 23 March the guys all
froze up
couldn't tell me diddly squat so my wife
said get out of there I'm takin over the
interviews and she did and I had to give
her quick basic training this is a rifle
this is a squad this is a PFC listen
general but she was quick a quick study
and she got it together and then she
started interviewing Greg and Greg's
would tell her all of these incredible
stories all the doors open and he just
poured it out and through that telling
became the incredible gold that's in
this story and that's the story of the
squad leader of the platoon leader the
machine gunner the cannoneer of the
pilot it's all of their their yarns kind
of wove through this rich tapestry that
makes this final rug which tells the
story of this battalion how it all came
about was in December of 1968 just shy
of Christmas at 3:00 in the morning the
phone rang and it was a colonel in the
Pentagon now in the Pentagon it six
o'clock in the morning to them is in six
o'clock in the morning all the way
around the world they don't care but it
was three o'clock in the morning where I
was so I groggily said hey tak were
there and said we have a request by name
for you to take over the sorriest the
worst they call it the hopeless
battalion out in the ninth division in
Vietnam and you're been asked for by a
general and with generals asked for
things everybody jumps and so we have to
pass it on to you our suggestion to you
is say no you commanded a battalion and
the hundred and first Airborne in
Vietnam early in the war you've done it
you now commanding a battalion and I was
a commanding of Italian at Fort Lewis
training soldiers for Vietnam and just
that day before I was sitting up on the
top of Mount Ranier
anybody here been to Mount Ranier all
right sitting up at the top of Mount
Rainier in three feet of snow training
my soldiers for Vietnam you get the
picture
and so the guys that we suggest you say
no and you go off to war college and to
bigger and better things and all of that
and I said I thought about it for
probably the sum total of oh maybe three
seconds and I said I'm out of here
I'll be on the next plane I got my
toothbrush and didn't make my wife too
happy and off I trotted to Vietnam and
got a good look at this battalion and I
seen a lot of battalions in the previous
23 years that I'd been a soldier and in
those 23 years I'd spent five years at
platoon level and then I'd commanded ten
companies artillery infantry armor
armored CAV Raider every kind of
different outfit you could imagine so
and now my third battalion so I had a
fair idea as an old carpenter might have
what was in my toolbox and how to build
a good house and but I looked at this
patina oh man this house is so
demolished it'll never come together it
was the greatest challenge that I think
that a soldier had had in a long long
time
it was on its butt full-stop and one of
my first experiences besides seeing
machine guns red with rust and rifles
red with rust and an ammunition
laying in the mud and soldiers running
around anybody in Vietnam is 69 because
I think this was kind of standard-issue
in Vietnam at that time for wasn't just
this battalion but I thought it was just
this baton and soldiers running around
with peace symbols and doing P stuff and
bopping around there was a funny smell
and the in the air that you couldn't buy
at the corner drugstore and and one of
my first tho encounters with one of the
soldiers were there peace symbols and
graffiti all over there hell helmets
liner there is a little cloth liner that
you use to break up the silhouette of
the helmet which is green but because
was not white and snow and all that
stuff it really was green jungle foliage
and things like suppose they had a war
and nobody came and all kinds of stuff
like that and that one one little emblem
that somewhat attracted me was this
thing that said FTA and I mean this FTA
was that big across the front of his
helmet I thought I got a kindred soul
man somebody that joined the army the
reason I joined the army which was fun
travel adventure so I bought that to
this young sergeant and said FTA what
does that mean he looked down and he
started pawing the ground with his boots
as well tell me what that means huh he
said sure it means up but I can't say it
on public television but it's something
like fuzz the army and boy it brought
out my Irish straightaway so then from
then on it was the challenge of finding
out what was wrong with this unit and
and making it work now I had been
trained in Italy by World War two
sergeants who had fought from Africa
through Sicily and up to that rugged
spine of Italy which was the hardest
fighting for American forces in a
sustained manner in World War two it was
tough and these guys were pros and they
saw this little 15 year old kid
reporting to their unit the little pink
face and all that stuff and they'd seen
a lot of little kids get planted in
Africa in Sicily and on that long trip
up through Italy so they just picked up
a 2x4 and swatted me in the back of the
head because they came from the school
you get it right and training or you die
on the battlefield so that was how I was
trained for four hard years that was the
standard that that caused me to
understand what soldiering was all about
and that NCOs were the steel spine of
the unit they never saw an officer in
Italy the officers were always doing pay
call in batoning the pea
and riding around on horses and cars and
stuff and they still in the NCL is ran
everything and there was no
micromanagement it was you looked at
your platoon or company and decided what
training you're going to have as a
sergeant and you just wrote your own
training schedule never submitted it to
anybody and you did it and so what I
then had to do was take a look at this
battalion and determine how I was going
to fix it and it was in really bad shape
and I realized that from my experience
that there are no bad units none
whatsoever
there are no bad soldiers none
whatsoever
there are only bad leaders so the
problem with this battalion was there
were bad leaders so I had to figure out
who was bad and who was good now on day
one I looked over the battalion and saw
it was so raggedy and I the colonel that
that I replaced he got a Silver Star
a legion of merit and patted on the head
for doing a great job
the battalion had not encountered the
enemy in a successful manner in the
previous six months but it stacked up
600 wounded and dead so if the battalion
commander couldn't square the battalion
away and who should have squared it away
the sergeant major so first thing I did
was sergeant major get on the bird
you're out here why me sir I said if you
live this unit to be in this shape you
shouldn't be a sergeant major and you
shouldn't be a leader of men on the
chopper out here so that was basically
my approach for the next two months as I
never smiled and I was just this old
grouchy guy and I and I went out with
every company and I check out the
company commander realize good man bad
man make a bunch of marks in my head
then I'd go down to one is spittoon
spend about four or five hours without
Petunia on the same day then I'd go down
to one of his squads spend four or five
six hours with that squad and then at
the end of the day I had a whole
battalion to fight a jump in a chopper
and come home but I had a fair
good idea of a company be Conde C
Company D Connie and I kept a little
notebook on what was going on and I saw
the good men and the bad men who should
be out of there and who should stay and
take over and it was through that
three-week experience that I was able to
run this unit throughout the place
called the plain of reeds a very
beautiful vacation spot you must go
there along the Cambodian border that I
realized that I realized by the end of
that who was strong who was bad so then
I quick smart fired 59 lieutenants 8
captains and three majors boom boom boom
boom and the lieutenant would say where
should I go
I don't care walk down the road see if
you can hitchhike a ride and a
helicopter
you're not staying here because you're
not going to kill my soldiers now the
soldiers weren't so dumb and they said
well maybe this guy's for real you know
maybe we got somebody different he's
getting rid of all they know who
soldiers are the first ones that know
they're bad and he's getting rid of all
the bad guys and at the same time as I
saw a good guy come in then or
identified a good guy
you got that you've got this job you've
got that job so I put there were all of
these folks were good all they needed
was a light shine on them and a little
direction and they then took off and
turned the battalion around and before
you know it the Spirit came and the one
of the first things I'd always come from
airborne so airborne you salute airborne
all the way above the rest strike force
whatever kind of unit you're from and so
I thought well we needed that same thing
here so I said now when you're saluting
you will salute and say hardcore acondo
and I wanted to make them have that
airborne spirit now as well they would
think they were airborne soldiers that's
how it goes and when they responded if
an if they saluted the officer would
respond no fuzzing slack and
and everybody says oh that's Mickey
Mouse and they had a big joke about GI
Joe lifer that's what they call me and
suddenly there was a slow conversion and
suddenly they stood a little taller and
they walked a little prouder and they
were proud they belong to the hardcore
of the time and remember all that
graffiti on their helmets those green
helmets on the other side of that helmet
was the desert color the brown that you
see the boys wearing now is I get ready
to go to Kawai so I said well we
couldn't get new helmet liner covers so
I should turn him around but they said
look we're in the green jungle I don't
give a rat's ass turn the things around
so the incredible the fact that this had
was the Vietcong after Wellston stay
away from those Brown had it guys that
really mean
and so the battalion slowly turned
around and my next problem was to
realize that they didn't have the kind
of skill level that but my previous
battalion in the 101 had it had been
together for 10 years I had been in the
unit the 101st airborne for four years
the battalion had been the third
Battalion of the 187 of the 11th
airborne and later it was converted to
the first battle group 3 to 7 101 then
later was Camille of 's to reorganise
then it was converted to the first
battalion 3 to 7 Airborne Infantry but
many of those NCOs who memorize that
NCOs were still spying of any unit they
had been in that same battalion for all
of those years so they knew they knew
that battalion they never in one company
every soldier in the company had had the
name of their company which was a boo
tattooed on the left ankle and you
couldn't get in the company unless you
went down and got that tattoo so you can
imagine the pride they had they they
were together so long that they knew
their equipment so well that these old
sergeants could identify a water can
that had a Danny
10 years before from a parachute drop
say in Japan that's my water can water
cans are not serial numbered item that's
how well they knew their stuff so you
can imagine the cohesion you can imagine
the spirit the camaraderie the teamwork
that battalion had it could do anything
it could it could attack and withdraw to
night operations you name it it could do
it and to give you an illustration of
its great depth in one fight which was
in March of 1966 into Iwo anybody had
the pleasure of visiting to anyone there
we go quite a few folks here into a wall
we were in a terrible fight and my a
company had lost all of its officers
they were all down either dead or dead
or wounded all of the 10 sergeants were
down first sergeant was down so there
was no leadership left in the company
they were about 300 meters from where I
was I was with be commie and we were not
going to get blinken linked up with them
before dark they had a lot of dead and a
lot of wounded we needed to get a
perimeter quick smart I needed to
reconstitute the chain of command but I
couldn't get anybody I couldn't get
another Senior Sergeant or a captain in
there the s4 and all that good stuff no
way I could get him in there so I got on
the internal freak of a company and said
this is still six which was my callsign
is listen up any leader here and one of
the old voices well major hacker is out
that this is a Simpson down here in the
third squad 3rd platoon sergeant Simpson
I started Simpson you think you could
take that lash off put him in a
perimeter get him tight for the night
medevac your wounded out of there take
care of your dad and square him away
until dawn we can link up with you Roger
that sir been preparing for this job for
10 years that was the kind of depth that
we had in that unit where a squad leader
could become company commander now go
back to the draftee battalion the
battalion that were telling you about
here for example in only one company be
calm me I'll give you a
a classic example of the depth of
experience we had company commander was
16 months out of West Point he was the
most experienced guy in the unit his
senior sergeant was 14 months in the
army
. all of the leadership was shake and
bake
now shake and bake everybody know what
that is or should I explain it that is
very bright people were picked up an AIT
and said you're a lieutenant you're a
sergeant you're lieutenant you're a
sergeant then the sergeants went to a
reduced OCS Officer Candidate course
which was 11 weeks and the lieutenant
went to I think 16 weeks and then the
butterbar became the most dangerous
thing in the world a second lieutenant
and the sergeant became a squad leader
and or a pattern sorry if he was the
honor graduate he wasn't he made e6 or
e7 still sergeant now in my army you
didn't get a squad you wouldn't even in
consideration for squad 8 to 10 years
platoon 15 to 20 years so now you got
these these young inexperienced kids
running this unit the shake-and-bake so
there was no depth of experience so when
I analyzed this and said now God we were
salute and spread away were morale is
coming up these guys are no longer thing
I think I'm Attila the Hun and I was
there about I brought my first sergeant
sorry major in with me who had been with
me in Korea in the same unit he'd also
been with me and Fort Campbell together
and also a First Sergeant in my 132 7
battalion and the first tour so we were
tight and and he became sergeant major
and I said Bob you go to the left I'll
go to the right just kick ass take names
get things squared away and that's how
we did things and we started slowly
slowly turning the battalion around but
I realized that because of the level of
experience we would never be able to
ever achieve what we had in the
101 because we just couldn't do all the
tricks that were necessary to do so then
I came upon the idea of specialization
and I was going to treat the battalion
kind of like you treat a dumb dog and I
gave each company a particular mission
and that's all they would do one trick
you know dumb dog jump over the ball
roll on your back and go whatever it
happened to be and so the first way of
doing this was a company became
long-range ambushed we were in water you
have to understand what the terrain was
like we were in water up to our waist
and mud up to our waist all of the time
you could never leave a company out more
than four days without immersion foot
occurring an immersion foot would put a
hole in your and your foot or leg but
like a bullet what had gone through it
and it would knock out a company in a
minute so you could stay no longer than
four days so alert company was split in
half into two big strong patterns and
they operated outside the fan the fan is
11 point to 105 in those days a 105 and
that's exactly 11 - there's the gun
there he reached out there and that
comes out of living - I mean God gave me
that it's like a glitch and figure out
what the pan was and so I always put a
company outside the fan because I wanted
Charles to tap a con they thinking it
was little eight man ambush and he finds
sixty really tough hombres and I could
have helicopters on him gunships within
about seven to ten minutes so they were
bait and they knew they were bait and
then B company was a ranger company they
slipped into the darkness and operated
as a ranger unit stealth surprise
ambushing enemy out drilling the enemy
and so on C Company was short-range
ambush eight seven men ambushed patrol
slip out every night and they also split
in two so half we're drying out back at
their fire bases and training and the
other half
out doing their ambush thing because
they could only do it for four days and
then Delta Company was airmobile and
ambush and the recon platoon was
deactivated and they became the sniper
platoon every man in that platoon was a
volunteer was an expert marksman had the
combat infantry badge and was very
squared away as a warrior there were
twenty men in the sniper platoon they
killed one and 58 enemy soldiers and
didn't have one
friendly ki a which is a put the hurt on
Charles in a big way and so all of these
specializations work together and they
do it day in and day out and they became
expert on on Ranger or airmobile or
ambushing and then when intelligence or
when we figured that Charles was that
Charles was the enemy was in a
particular place we would end up I would
I would wouldn't act like the average
American unit that saw the enemy and
went and jumped on him I just let him it
ignored the enemy and let him cook and
let him stew until I went after him when
I wanted to go after him on the ground
that I wanted to go after him at the
time I wanted to go after him
so once I isolated a target then I would
bring in the alert company that was way
far out they'd sneak up and go to a
choke point it might take him four days
but they would be the backdoor of that
enemy and claim work on he would slip in
and go to other choke points and then a
Delta Company would sneak in that was a
ranger company and go to other choke
points and the snipers would be employed
night and day they flew night and night
in helicopters with starlight scopes and
in the daytime they set up in various
spots two men snipers talk about what do
you call it in Spanish Co nods or
something big Conan's
you had to be a very very brave hombre
to be doing that kind of stuff and then
on the morning of an attack Wham their
mobile company Babel Company B Company
would land right smack on top of the
enemy now what the enemy do did they
fight or did they run they ran
where'd they run to all the doors that
we sealed up in our guys went to toot
toot and victory after victory started
coming to these boys the way and and
these were lopsided victories for
example the last victory on may the 22nd
1969 that I tell about in the book it
relates to a similar story we did it
just as I described to you we ended up
with three American slightly wounded and
Jerry Sullivan a boy from Claymore
County that got a bad mind but quite
seriously wounded that was that for
wounded and we kill over 200 enemy it
was a force far larger than ours it was
a reinforced battalion we were a light
skinny light battalion and we ended up
destroying that but reinforced battalion
and kind of winding them up taking their
colors in their logbook and all of that
good stuff and so it shows you what kids
with proper leadership can do now the
troops really weren't saying oh heck we
love you when I first came there because
at that time in Vietnam there was a
thing called fragging and if any leader
was strong and hard and bad from of the
squad leader platoon sergeant company
commander battalion commander he might
wake up one night in his hole with
something rolling around and it was a
hand grenade which comes the term
fragging fragmentation Hand Grenade and
we were averaging about a thousand
American ki a
here from fragging at that time so the
first sergeant sorry major came to me
and said boss there's little problem
here I says what's that hard nature and
he said they're the boys and become you
put a little price on your head nice
well how much is it
he says 3,500 Isis forget it that's
nothing so we just kept going in the few
weeks later says boss it's 10,000 now I
said we're going to do something about
this isn't serious but eventually the
troops realized that what I was about
and what the leadership of the battalion
was about was keeping them alive don't
sit there and get hammered as they had
been don't sit there and react to the
enemy but go in there and take the war
to the enemy make him run what did
George Patton say about where's my
friend West what did he say about don't
kill those bastards or bastard everyone
away you're hungry
ya know bastard ever won a war by dying
for their country and it was you I had
to develop in there my principle of war
the offense take the ward the enemy once
they realized that they could take the
word of the enemy and they weren't
getting blasted apart by those
horrendous mines of three things of war
the three considerations of war are
whether the terrain and the enemy and in
the mekong delta of all the battlefields
i have visited as a soldier or as a war
correspondent which is a little bit more
than a dozen i ain't seen no place worse
than the mekong delta because of the
weather because of the terrain and
because of the enemy the weather if it
wasn't raining it was raining and you
know about the mud and the wet and
you're always wet and you're always
muddy you never dried out and if you
found a dry patch anywhere in the Delta
the ants owned it and those ads were VC
ants and they'd fight you for that piece
of ground and I have guys in the
battalion have told me stories of
soldiers in that battalion in a
firefight with bullets nap and over
their head get bit
by Anson stand up it was so bad it's
what those fans thought so and then the
third element was you had the enemy and
the enemy wasn't so much better someone
the enemy what weren't amateurs these
guys were hard core pros they're great
Grandaddy started it all and they beat
the French they beat the Japanese they
beat the French again
they beat the Saigon government and now
they called us long nosed as you know
why now they were having their little go
with the long noses like we and they
were doing a pretty good job on us so
you were looking at fourth and fifth
generation warriors it was embedded in
them they were totally dedicated to the
cause hey they wore a little red star up
here they carried Soviet gear they
didn't know communism from I screen him
ISM what they were about was
independence they wanted to get rid of
us so they were fighting with that same
kind of gusto that our Patriot ancestors
fought with in 1776 against the British
and what what they did was they were not
going to give us an inch and in order to
and they knew the battlefield they knew
how to most American units fought so
what we had to do their advantage was
very much like if you were sitting in a
darkened audience and I'm on a stage and
it's all lit up
you're the guerrilla and every advantage
is yours because I'm on the stage and
you can sit there and say well the guard
is asleep there that machine gun does
look like it works there there's a good
Avenue of approach here and this guy's a
real sleeper we can get in there in a
minute and they can eyeball and check
out every one of your strengths and your
vulnerabilities they know your
weaknesses and they know where to hit
you
so the key thing there was to shut the
lights off on the stage
and so the first step was to flip the
lights off and the next step was to
steal a page from the Vietcong and used
their very tactics against them and
that's precisely what we did we took the
war to them and in the end a battalion
achieved this incredible record of
killing almost and I know it's certainly
the ladies here would think that that
that soldiers are butchers and all of
that stuff but that was what we did that
was our business and the battalion
killed 2,600 enemy soldiers at the price
of 25 of American soldiers the ratio was
1 to 100 if every battalion in the
United States Army had had copied our
tactics with their equally dumb soldiers
or equally badly trained soldiers
equally badly led soldiers but just
replicated what we did all hundred
battalions Ho Chi Minh could have not
handled the pain he would have gone on
his hat and zipped on his bicycle all
the way back to Hanoi and said I ain't
going there to those Americans get out
of there and we could have won the war
tactically we could have never won the
war strategically because of the Saigon
government they were bombs as simple as
that
they were mostly Catholics controlling a
Buddhist country you do the math and
they all had bank accounts in Paris so
so what the army did after this great
achievement on the part of this all
draftee unit was they decided to what
they called vietnamisation and that
meant start bringing American units home
and announced that we'd won the war and
the Vietnamese could handle it because
that we'd build them up into this big
Jack Dempsey and they were lean and mean
and and could carry the carry on the war
and finally defeat the the opponent and
they took the battalion it was the first
battalion in the US Army in via
infant battalion to return to the united
states and they sent him to hawaii they
gave them all away now lay is a flower
you know the army was just not that
broad-minded and they then patted him on
the head scratched their belly and
disbanded them and all of the lessons
that they learned were lost totally lost
and then the Army in its humiliation
over the execution of the war in Vietnam
because they were fighting World War two
they didn't want to know about how to
really fight the war they thought they
could use this huge sledgehammer and
just beat the opponent to death as they
did the Nazis and the Germans and
anybody else have you ever gotten our
way and so they were so humiliated
because of the Vietnam experience that
they wanted to forget it and they took
all those lessons that were learned by
the hardcore battalion and a lot of
other units there and put him under a
rug and got some superglue and and and
sealed that sucker to the ground and
they were lost and lost forever so what
we have here is a story of one battalion
which is an emblem of every unit that
fought in Vietnam that fought the war
correctly and their lessons are so
incredible for this long war that we're
now engaged in because we need to dust
off those lessons and so they're so
applicable in this war that's going to
rage for the next ten twenty thirty
years and those heroes that fought in
Vietnam many of them came home and was
treated as I explained to you and felt
feel very much that their service was in
vain without realizing that that's not
the case that the case in fact is that
their lessons that they learn will be
passed on to their children today you
stop and think about it their kids are
just about old enough to be our soldiers
and
understand the Philippines Somalia
Saddam in Iraq in the months to come
that will be carrying the war of the
future so there lessons learned will
keep their kids alive and their
grandkids alive in the war of the
futures in his terrible terrible war of
terrorism so the end result of the book
which I hope it turns on the nation
because the nation to realize what noble
heroes are Vietnam veterans are and do
this for all of us so we can all have
healing is to welcome them home and and
also to understand that their lessons
are absolutely priceless and they'll
keep us kind of bring us into the
winning circle in this war on terrorism
so I thank you for listening to this
long harangue and I'm happy to answer
questions on Vietnam on the book or on
the war that we're now involved in thank
you yes sir
and I promise you this is my first drink
today the cup the kernel that yeah that
that I replaced he went to the Pentagon
he was the army chief of staff's aid to
camp and he made full colonel and then
he retired and and I'm sure that he's
hanging his head in shame for his
conduct and in a way and I thought about
I didn't use his name because I didn't
want to humiliate him because he was a
victim of the system and the system was
what we should have had in Vietnam
was professional soldiers go over with
her battalions and stay with her
battalions until a certain time then
bring their battalions back let those
who wanted to get out out keep the
battalion together the NCOs the officers
and put in new people and train them and
let them go home this this Lieutenant
Colonel was in our fourth year of war
out in Vietnam scratching for his CIB he
had never been in combat never been in
Vietnam before he was not qualified to
command a battalion as were so many of
the commanders in Vietnam and we can
never allow that to happen again
yes sir right behind you
China or Russia could have could have
gotten involved it could have escalated
into a larger thing can get
the question is was there a threat of
Russia or China jumping into the war
both had jumped into the war they were
materially supporting they were
providing fighter pilots advisors in
throughout Vietnam Chinese and Russian
advisors providing all kinds of
high-tech
intercept equipment and technology so
they were they were very much deep in
the war because what the war was about
at the higher level it was really the
cold war being fought in somebody else's
backyard and so the Soviets wanted to
bleed us just like we a few years later
bled them in Afghanistan when we
supported their opponents so that was a
great consideration
remember Korea was still in everybody's
mind we Chinese jumped in the war in
November of 1950 and really cleaned on a
clock gave our army its most decisive
victory and it's in its history driving
him back from the Yellow River almost
300 klicks to beyond a south of Seoul so
everybody was very antsy about about
that possibility not being a strategist
I couldn't go much further than that but
it was it was certainly a consideration
of why we were so timid early in the war
about knocking off the bridges between
northern on North Vietnam and China to
cut out those supplies the railroad
capability of bringing and stuff and
knocking out the bases and in their
sanctuaries in Laos Cambodia and North
Vietnam which was a major mistake of the
world yes sir
maybe you can answer this this confused
question that I've read about since
Vietnam they said that initially the
average grunt didn't fire his weapon in
Vietnam and then I think you did a study
after that and said yes he did he just
didn't hit anything all right which is
true there was a study in World War two
conducted by slam Marshall it was kind
of a vanished
study but it got him a very very
prominent place in the military's mind
the generals didn't know so they bleed
slam it slam made it all up and and you
got the honor here right here in this
town but his most famous book is a hoax
which said infantry didn't fire their
rifles in World War two when I
questioned where did all his dead
Germans come from and so that wasn't
true but but ironically his his
influence on the generals changed
infantry training and put a lot more
emphasis on marksmanship and live-fire
exercises and all of those things so it
really worked to our benefit my
experience and a couple tours in Vietnam
was I never saw an American soldier ever
have any problem of zinging off a few
rounds if anything hey man you're going
too much you're certain too much so III
don't think that was a problem right
Jerry and my good buddy there and a
great battalion commander during this
time yes sir yes sir
and your opinion sir do you think that
we ought to go after Saddam Hussein now
and finish the job
that Bush should have done when he was
there but one question of time I'm
almost 72 we'll get the second one here
and the question is should we go after
Saddam Hussein and my view is absolutely
yes for many many reasons and not just
the sight that he broken every promise
in every treaty that he signed with the
Stormin Norman on 28 February 1971 1 2
he has weapons of mass destruction
chemical and biological that we know
doesn't have a few he has tons and tons
and tons of this stuff and he's used it
against his own people
so he's shown that he would use this
stuff he is not too far according to
intelligence to being able to have a
nuke weapon heating strap on those
missiles he's got which would change the
whole dimension of power in that region
and
and cause a whole bunch of people to
hurt meaning is missiles scuds or I have
been greatly improved by North Korea and
and by that the graciousness with Bill
Clinton providing China with a lot of
technology that got into North Korea
that got into into Iraq and I reckon
that he's got to go and I think he will
go and it would be much like what we had
in 64 when Goldwater said we're going
there and help EJ said no we're not but
then we had the election and off we went
so maybe after November would be the
time to go at 1 and 2 it's perfect time
in weather because it's cold out in the
desert and our boys are going to have to
be really covered up in their little
tense because that they Saddam Husein is
going to know that he's going to go down
and so as a result he will surely use
weapons of mass destruction chemical or
biological as Adolf Hitler would have
and made the 8:45 when he was going down
so we've got to protect our soldiers and
I think they're damn well from what I
can find out the new equipment a new
protection and detection stuff is
dynamite and we'll be able to get
through that so will it be fast I think
that will be very much like Desert Storm
one with a much smaller force
our weapons are smarter our tanks are
far more capable when they were that
then and they were dynamite then but the
new model is far superior to the ones we
had in Desert Storm you saw in
Afghanistan what airpower can do now
with all all that smart stuff and when
that was our smart stuff back in Desert
Storm I couldn't even get in the first
grade and compared to what we have today
so I think that it would be a quick
victory and it'll send a whole big
signal to the rest of the terrorist
States that are supporting these little
bastards that are
attacking us who are just trying to
destroy our way of life what they're
about is a destruction of Christianity
destruction of Judaism and they want to
take our civilization and whack it back
to the 10th century so we'll be in tight
in with them and that ain't going to
happen ok yes sir just a vague question
of sir
why don't you write or expose or somehow
sort of write something that identifies
then tells us about the military
industrial congressional complex that
started this war I mean weren't the
grunts and the NAM sacrificed for the
almighty dollar well I think that your
question Dwight David Eisenhower said to
the nation in 1960 you need coined the
expression the military industrial
congressional complex the mick and it
certainly exists but the mick is not
something that we discovered it's not
something new it's been going on since
man used the jawbone as an ass as a
military weapon and it's up to we
citizens to turn that around I was very
moved recently when the President of the
United States and the Secretary of
Defense Donald Rumsfeld who I consider a
very outstanding American a real Patriot
a guy that really knows what's going on
killed the Crusader artillery piece
thirteen billion dollar Cold War weapon
did we don't need it and I'm an
instrument and I'm belong to the queen
of battle but I'll tell you what I have
great respect for artillery who I have a
king of battle but it was a wise
decision on the part of the president
and the Secretary of Defense which was a
mick weapon by the way and guess whose
daddy was sitting on the board of the
company that made the crusader George
Bush's five
and this our president had the guts to
say kill it
imagine the phone call he got back yes
sir
is this the last question yes sir
I be the last question is sort of
Philips line I'm not sure you the last
question this is the this is the referee
here okay well um do you not think that
this country needs Patriots like you and
me that are willing to fight without
questioning but also the Jane Fonda's
that forces the government to justifier
Wars well I think the country has a
great number of Patriots and they have
certainly stood tall over the years
since we became a a republic and I'm
quite sure it will continue to I see no
genetic change to the American youth
they're just as good and toughness as
they've always been all they need is the
same thing as that hopeless battalion
needed was a little leadership yes sir
all the information we're getting from
the president about sending federal
troops to our border how do you feel
about that I don't feel about that
because my expertise is a very limited
thing remember the dumb dog I know about
the military and I try to understand
that in every way from from the basic
weapon to the tactic that's employed to
the strategy but I try to I don't know
about that so I can't answer because
it's outside of my area of knowledge I'd
like to know about it I think it has to
be studied
yes sir you great our military is doing
a proper job basic military training the
question is do I think that the military
is doing a good job in training well
let's start with the training of
noncommissioned officers I don't think
that we've ever had a better training
system in the history of the United
States Army for the education of our
NCOs I don't think we've ever had a
finer NCO corps and I think that the
education of our young officers is has
been really fine-tuned
where it is also excellent from the
basic horse from ROTC West Point right
up to command and General Staff College
what bothers me is what I see going on
at places of initial entry training ie
basic training and if you look at my
website which is www.hyken.com is that
what do you think of the training here
it's fun man it wasn't fun when I was
there and so if you have a look at my
website and read that piece where we
have we have really lost sight of what
it takes to how to build a fire to forge
a sword in basic training to instill the
disciplining still the the basics that
you need to survive on the battlefield
and that has been lost it's been lost by
the last decade of kinder gentler
consideration for others BS and but I
see that also turning around I see that
the the new general who was running Fort
Jackson is an Airborne Ranger that
dropped and Grenada
often in Panama tough and mean as a
snake and the guy that he replaced was
this jerk that bragged to me when I
interviewed him that he had the highest
casualties during a desert storm and I
suggest general they were they were
caused by friendly fire your own fire
he turned red yes sir in reference to
the news coverage during the war in
Vietnam um naturally it was pretty
pretty graphic and pretty well reported
in the news media what is your opinion
on that and so Lee you feel hey look
then we can come back to that second one
uh well the the media coverage of the
war in Vietnam was was much different
from Desert Storm where the where the
press corps was kind of locked in hotels
and not allowed to go look at the
battlefield in Vietnam was it was just
kind of open they could jump in a
chopper go out and report the war and
the American people had a very excellent
idea of the war anyway because the
minute we started putting draftees in
the war then the truth started coming
out when my brigade from the 101 which
was all regular marched over in May of
1965 we were filling body bags no one
said a word because those body bags were
all regulars and the regulars were from
the other side the railroad tracks and
their daddies wore blue shirts and there
was not a whole bunch of noise in the
paper in the paper it wasn't until the
draft came and the bankers son and the
doctor's son and the lawyer son and all
of that started filling body bags when
the protests started beginning so that
gives you a suggestion that maybe it's
best if you have a serious war like that
to ensure that we have a cross-section
of the population that they all don't
have an opportunity to go to Oxford
yes sir
we're your friends that admires and
we're here because we we like the
message that you you put out on many
occasions what what do you get back the
other way from the establishment from
the Pentagon from the leaders who don't
seem to change generation to generation
do they call you - they write you do you
get angry messages well what do you hear
from them ah what I am told at the top
is that the senior leadership of the
military go to work in the morning and
you go through the mall of the Pentagon
and there's bookstores and they sell
newspapers there and there's the
Washington Post which is the local
newspaper and they get the paper and
they take it to their desk and they lay
it on their desk then they don't look at
the front page they go to the obituary
page to see if that old son of a [ __ ]
is dead yet so it has it just hasn't
changed and I have really thought it out
and a friend of mine was general rhymer
who was the main man of the army and I
had I've talked to him 10 15 times a day
and and I by email mainly provided him
with kamo he invited me to speak to all
of his generals his commanding generals
and boy that was like kind of like Adolf
Hitler at a rabbi convention and I and
what I found among that business not all
but the senior brass of the United
States military specifically the Navy
the United States Air Force in the
United States Army not the United States
Marine Corps is total denial and it
might be that they went to West Point
for four years they've served for 35 36
years they got 40 years service that's
their organization they made that
organization and they can't accept
what's going on and their problem is it
was the problem of Vietnam was simply
this that the
I was not in touch with the bottom
meaning the big brass did not go down
and talk to the grunt if they did if
you'd had chesty pullers if you'd have
had folks like George Patton they would
have gone talked to the grunt the grunt
and said this rifle doesn't work this
tactic it sucks and so on and we would
have been squared away so they got to
get out of there IV towers and get down
talking to the folks who walk in the
walk and talking the talk the guys that
won the brilliant war in Afghanistan and
that's the Green Berets and folks like
that a lot of good folks out there
they're doing a hell of a job for all of
us
thank you very much david hackworth
currently writes a nationally syndicated
column called defending America his
books include
about face hazardous duty and price of
honor his latest steal my soldier's
hearts is published by rugged land
online at rugged land calm if you'd like
a videotape copy of the program's you've
been watching this weekend or anyway